[Music]  with more people living and working in  and around rangiora  there's increased pressure on car  parking  it's estimated that within the next 30  years we'll require up to  800 new car parking spaces the council  has already bought and leased land in  the town centre here  for parking but long term that's not  going to be enough and so  we're looking at constructing a car  parked building  we've already set aside six million in a  previous long-term plan  but we'll need more than that to meet  future demand  the council was proposing another nine  million dollars from  2028 and that's for a building that's  going to provide  up to 280 additional car parks  alternatively we could bring forward  funding and build it sooner  or defer the project all together and  look at other options for managing  parking  visit waimakariri.govt.enz forward slash  let's talk to take a look at the options  and to have your safe  you